[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today
Courtney's with us Courtney is in
Colorado Springs hi Courtney welcome to
the Ramsey Show hi thank you so much for
having me sure what's
up my question is how do I protect or
how does my husband and I protect our
finances against his money hungry
ex-wife money hungry ex-wife
why would she have any access to your
finances she's called the ex-wife for a
reason um
basically our main concern is could she
pull more child support when she finds
out that he's been
married I'm I'm I'm sorry would she get
child support increased because he got a
raise is that what you
said um because we got married could she
take she doesn't get more child support
because you got married married child
support's based on his income not
yours
gotcha okay so how else would the crazy
ex have access to your husband's
money that was the only way I was
thinking I've heard that they do yearly
audits they do someone they do because
your husband your husband has children
and he should support those children and
the law agrees with that idea
correct and if he gets more money as his
income he's supposed to give more to his
children that's that's not a money
hungry ex that's just dad taking care of
his
kids right has she contacted him is she
making threats or is this just all kind
of in your head right now what could
happen um she hasn't contacted him I
guess this is just me trying to make
sure we protect
ourselves
okay well you're in good shape as long
as your husband is willing to give the
legal percentage of his income to his
children under the law for child support
which he legally and morally should do
um if if you if you want protection from
that I can't help you but as long as
he's willing to do that you don't need
protection from anything else she can't
get anything else she has no access and
or if your husband is spineless and just
gives her money because she yells at him
or
something I mean has he got that problem
um no she's not okay so he's not he
doesn't just hand her money just because
she puffs up or something right correct
okay that's just a behavior issue that's
not a legal or a financial issue but
yeah I mean sometimes people are
intimidated by their exes or whatever
and um we have to just kind of correct
that by saying you know X in front is a
reason yes X means no mo no mo that's
what that means we're making sure the
courts decide how this goes down not his
emotions or her and so that that's the
important part it sounds like this is
largely right now just a fear versus a
reality yeah like you have discovered
that no one likes your husband's ex oh
well that's really you know you know
makes because she's a greedy jerk okay
whatever that's fine no trouble uh but
she's still over there and she's the ex
and the only involvement you have is
just around the children and so we'll
try to be nice and pleasant and give the
appropriate amount of Child Support
as long as you're trying to do that then
uh I don't think you're going to have
any issues there's nothing nothing she
can just you know or unless she shows up
at the doorstep and your husband just
caves and starts handing her money but
that's a husband issue that's not a
protection issue then yeah this this was
simpler than I thought it would be I
thought there was some crazy stuff going
on but it's just child support as far as
we can tell yeah so yeah very reasonable
well there's a real Dynamic when you're
the new wife and the ex is over there
and the distance is crazy that's a still
connection that's a dynamic yeah those
kids are still going to be in his life
so you're going have to learn to manage
it yeah it's a it's a thing create your
free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life